so you see a lot of football when you
don't finish work come here help a bit
all volunteers is quite quite amazing
some people come to me saying what the
hell are you doing with Bako
you are tracking it down
so bad
we did sorry but
the condition now it is for a better
future
this afternoon at about five o'clock I
got pictures in from
just right outside see one learns more
the tear gas and some bullets I was
expecting they extend this video just to
you know show that hey don't do anything
we got guns we got all the gears out or
they are actually doing something to my
that they're trying to
q ases place
all this down
want more download the aj+ mobile app
and join the conversation available in
your app store now